eu nasci mulher preta numa cidade
racista machista e misógina feito
vitória então num estado como o espírito
santo que os índices de mortalidade de
mulheres negras são alarmantes e é
alarmante também os índices de violência
contra a juventude negra ou seja a
sociedade está falando pra gente é
difícil viver né
porque se é difícil ver de novo e depois
velho quer dizer se vai morrer uma hora
e se você morrer é pra bater também
agradecer mesmo né
e quando a gente fala e fala das
dificuldades de ser uma pessoa negra
pode parecer mimi vitimismo pode parecer
não essa coisa da cabeça de quem não é
negro sem generalizar mas normalmente
você vê vitimismo e mimi e aí eu venho
falar em nome de uma comunidade que
preza pelo mínimo que eu respeito eu não
to nem pedindo mais pra colocar se
colocar no meu lugar eu vou pedir no
mínimo respeito e vejam como a gente não
tem o hábito de conjugar o verbo
respeitar o que a gramática é claro né
é eu respeito ele respeita
nós respeitamos é muito simples mas a
gente não se apega e isso e aí fica esse
jogo vulgo essa confusão de que eu não
tinha respeito eu não tolero e pronto
só que o preconceito é preconceito
racismo racismo
o racismo é condicional a pessoa sofre
só porque nasceu preta
ela é maldita desde o nascimento por um
único fator é preta
vocês conseguem imaginar como isso é
dilacerante uma vida toda como sumo ti
lá as nossas almas ao passar dos tempos
como é difícil construir e reconstruir
vidas é auto estima
diante de um passado todo de violência
de que pretendia gostosa de mulatas agem
tele globeleza de você até que é
competente mas só pôde realizar o seu
cabelo né de amigos que não são tão
racistas porque tem amigos pretos porque
já se relacionaram com mulheres negras
nunca apresentaram para as famílias mas
se relacionaram com ela estão observando
como racismo está implantado na vida da
gente o tempo todo como tá aí
nos diálogos nossos das mesas nas
brincadeiras e alguém ainda acha que
mimi vitimismo enfim vou contar uma
história muito rapidamente aqui souberam
muitos anos fui chamada
representatividade porque blogueira não
é uma coisa que nós mulheres negras
tínhamos muito direito de ser né
então eu fui chamada representatividade
cada vez mais falava sobre as coisas do
meu povo do meu cabelo da minha
maquiagem porque sou vaidosa sim
obrigado de nada não me sinto culpado
por isso também é ea gente não tinha
muitas possibilidades e eu já estava
discutindo muitas coisas questionando
outros modificando sua consultora
jurídica trabalhei muitos anos na
iniciativa privada inclusive a última
com tecnologia que foi uma experiência
nova de libertação de idéias que também
restabeleceu e ressignificar idéias na
minha vida
mas eu fiquei grávida e grávida eu
pensei 'bom eu sou preto meu marido é
preta muito óbvio que eu vou ter uma
criança preta né
e mais é um menino era um menino que
desde a minha barriga já era um suspeito
padrão um oi na barriga é já tinha todas
as características e fenótipos
estabelecidos já era um suspeito padrão
e as coisas vão mudando dentro de mim da
preocupação porque quando você sai né da
do conforto de se deter que se proteger
para ter que protejam seu acordo aumenta
e aí meu filho já tinha nascido e meu
marido fomos para uma praia famosa aqui
em vitória nunca frente do mesmo
quiosque que nós vamos há 12 anos em
nosso filho tinha um ano e meio começou
a brincar com outra criança não negra e
os pais falaram com a criança assim eu
não quero você brincando com esse tipo
de gente
oi tipo de gente que tipo de gente meu
filho pode ser com um ano e meio
que tipo de gente
o filho de cada um aqui pode ser com e
mail porque meu filho mal sabia falar
com ninguém
o racismo vez e aí eu resolvi sair da
bolha
eu eu fiquei pensando que eu vou fazer
com a educação do meu filho eu vou
preparar para o mundo ou preparar outra
ele e aí eu que sou meio pink com os
amigos meu cérebro
falei nós vamos dominar o mundo eu quero
preparar meu filho quer preparar o mundo
para ele eu vou sair da bolha e um belo
dia eu sentada num bar com a minha
melhor amiga clare saúde é um ato que a
gente tem que as melhores idéias que a
gente tem normalmente os bens toques são
nos bairros
né e eu falei de um projeto que eu tinha
porque a gente freqüentava muitas muitas
feiras encontros fora do estado ea gente
é muito encontro de cacheado né
aqui eu tô vendo todo mundo sabendo
cuidar do cabelo fazer por banti mas eu
vi aquela galera com essa força na rua
porque só quem tem uma estética negra
sabe como é que é difícil sustentava na
rua a gente via que nos eventos
as meninas iam todas arrumadas às vezes
travestidos de negro mas no dia a dia
qual estamos importando aí eu comecei a
falar pra mim mesmo para bora falar de
zumbi de não dar para falar que a áfrica
é um continente no país para falar das
cores para falar das vitórias da parte
boa de que a gente vem de um povo livre
que foi escravizada não escravo e que a
gente mente livremente forte porque
vamos combinar que um povo que resistiu
há tantas mazelas e ainda é a maioria da
população do país cara é um povo forte
ou não e aí a gente criou é ela me
perguntou na verdade a marisa me
perguntou o que faltava para fazer isso
tudo né porque eu sempre usei produtos
feitos por empreendedores negros
eu sempre gostei muito de usar a
estética urbana da rua do hip hop com do
samba com as coisas da minha sexualidade
para trabalhar então eu era capaz mesmo
de trabalhar de terno e turbante essa
roupa e um scarpin e o mercado não está
preparado para essas coisas né
muitas pessoas não estão nem na rua e aí
aquela isso me perguntou tá faltando que
pra você
óbvio dinheiro né
mas tava faltam coragem e ela falou
assim prazer coragem a minha melhor
amiga me deu o maior dos investimentos
que eu já tive
ela me deu coragem e aí eu percebi que
naquele momento em diante não caminhava
só e era isso que tornava parada
especial porque a gente encontrando
outras mulheres um caminho ea venda do
que as nossas histórias eram semelhantes
a solidão da mulher negra às os
alisamentos no cabelo e usar uma toalha
no cabelo enrolado é fingir que tem
cabelo que balança porque a gente faz é
isso a gente fazia isso não existiam nem
produtos para o nosso cabelo imagina
então cabelo cumprido balança e porque
tem que balançar e porque tem que ficar
para baixo e por que que tem que ser
estabelecido e por que que eu priscila
mulher preta que sou cheia de curva que
fala exclusivamente ballons pescoço e
tem um cabelo que quando eu solto black
nome porque que eu tenho que ser outra
pessoa
vocês estão vendo como racismo de
lacerda lei a ponto de a gente ter
coragem de virar para uma mulher preto e
falava você não é tão preto assim a você
é preto mas é tem feições femininas a
ela é preta mas é legal
su preta aliás vou fazer outro parágrafo
que o brasil tem um negócio sensacional
que é chamar os outros de moreni pardo
né
eu não sei mas assim a gente está aqui
nesse ambiente todo mundo fala inglês
assim maravilhoso mas assim eu me lembro
que no inglês tem do neto né que é o
moreno e quando você vê o net em né
normalmente aquele italiano é do cabelo
escuro o crespo também que a cecília não
tenho cabelo
crespo mais branco ué preta e aí a gente
transforma isso a brasileira não ser que
a gente faz com isso aí a gente usa o
termo pardo
alguém aqui já comprou um carro parado
alguém que já passou em uma loja
sensacional e falou eu quero aquela
camisa parda e uma casa partida de
janelinhas brancas
alguem ja qe fúcsia é cor marsala é cor
até o papagaio goinski vocês foram uma
loja de tinta é cortar essa colar a
pagar algo em que eu fiz uma pesquisa
maravilhosa para mim falar pra vocês mas
se vocês votarem lá pardo não tem é
porque pago não é co
e você já viu alguma coisa sem cor que
fosse lembrada notada respeitada
apontada face lembro e porque eu ia
gostar de ser uma dessas coisas
e por que eu mereço ser uma dessas
coisas estão vendo como racismo de
lançar como a gente multiplica
não tenho medo de falar você é uma negra
linda você uma preta ainda tem gente que
não sabe lidar com a palavra preta ou
negra ficou com medo de falar não fala
você de cor indicou não todo mundo
indicou que vocês conseguem ver que todo
mundo indicou né
uma cor branca com a maré ou mais
amarela é uma cor mais avermelhada
método de cook vira para o próximo e
fala você aquela negra linda que ela
preta linda ou preto
não não por favor não repassem o
discurso racista vão parar com isso
vamos parar com isso
mas enfim depois do encontro das pretas
no encontro das pretas
a gente fez
é uma reunião com discussões em uma
feira já foi empreendedorismo e nós
reunimos duas mil mulheres negras no
clube de pesca em santo antónio nós já
estamos indo pra nossa quarta edição ea
último reuniu 5 mil pessoas num único
dia entre homens e mulheres
famílias inteiras indo no encontro das
pretas ea gente virou assim a gente está
na lista do comum segundo o segundo
maior evento afros entrada do país
a gente só pede pra feira preta de são
paulo
e aí a gente se organizou é porque
mulher preta gente desculpa mas a gente
é poderosa demais né
vamos combinar eu tenho a gente
sobrevive
todos os dias a luta é grande
tá a luta é muito grande a luta é de
tratamento para abastecer o carro em que
o o o frentista se acha no direito de
olhar pra você e de falar com a
petinhada na direção como se ele pudesse
invadir esse meu espaço
tá é muita coisa junta o racismo o
machismo ea misoginia isso é muito sério
enfim a gente se organizou
virou uma associação temos uma sede
física no centro histórico de vitória
próximo ao palácio anchieta
e hoje eu tenho orgulho de falar que eu
sou presidente da única organização de
economia mista criativas em porcentual
for centrada e de protagonismo feminino
no país
nós temos sete projetos que andam
concomitantes todos de ação afirmativa
nenhum patrocinador nenhum edital
subsidiado pelo governo só metodologias
inteligentíssimas e criativos de auto
financiamento porque quando a gente vai
vender nosso produto por um iniciativa
privada a gente escuta assim ah mas isso
é preto
isso é racismo reverso
do racismo é reverso agências têm idéia
de como eu gosto é sério tá eu não vou
falar sobre racismo reverso aqui mas ele
procura no google por favor
tá e aí a gente conseguiu juntar uma
equipe sensacional de mulheres é que
consegue pensar essas ações afirmativas
uma atrás da outra uma atrás da outra
sendo estudada sendo falado e
referenciada no brasil inteiro e fora do
brasil
tudo aqui nem que a gente acha que não
ter tornado
enfim a parte importante eu acho dessa
caminhada encontro mulher negra
empoderada porque empoderamento tem uma
palavra sensacional que é poder né
e dá por dar poder é da autonomia e da
independência né da liberdade mas eu
também não acredito em alguém 100%
empoderado por que meios humanos e 100%
moderado é como se eu não preciso de
ninguém porque seja atingiu o negócio
ali do empoderamento significa que não
precisa de ninguém para te ajudar né e
essa vida deve ser chato também mas o
caminho é lindo e ele é sensacional para
a mulher negra que pega toda aquela vida
de educação racista de negatividade e de
mazelas e ressignifica para coisas
positivas é importante é que a gente
está caminhando junto a gente está
vivendo um momento importantíssimo é uma
revolução que é feminina preta e crespa
que eu tenho orgulho de estar junto com
outras várias mulheres na linha de
frente
mas o que eu queria dizer aqui pra vocês
é que a gente precisa parar de podar as
verdades
a gente precisa parar de limitar a vida
alheia seja ela com condicional comum é
o ser negro ou seja como o de escolha
de qualquer forma a gente precisa falar
e eu vim falar em nome dessas mulheres e
é por isso que eu queria terminar
falando uma coisa pra vocês
meu nome é priscila gama
eu sou uma mulher preta mulher preta
negra e eu sou linda
sou limpa olha sou saudável
sou educada sou competente
sou forte sou resistente e eu me orgulho
[Aplausos]